Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel
what if episode 7 trailer also basically a
trailer for the rest of the series.
Like a midseason trailer.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs and obviously
their hyping up the big multiverse avengers
endgame level crossover event they're having
with all the different universe version of the characters
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes there
will be a what if season 2 of 9 episodes,
it's out of the gonna try and release it next year
So want to wait too long for them to continue
the story after the what if finale this year
but careful for spoilers for everything that
happened on the show so far if you have been
watching the episodes.
But if it wasn't clear from all the different
episodes already all the different episodes
up to this point have taken place in different
universes as the watcher narrates the beginning
of each episode.
He talks about how people create nexus events
like on Loki by making some different choice
during a critical event in the previous sacred
timeline version of events the infinity saga
of movies so far as we call the sacred timeline
basically even though they kind of blew that
up at the end of Loki.
But when the characters do that they create
a branch timeline that eventually over time
turns into a fully alternate reality during
the Loki series.
They call that moving past redline when a
branch timeline moved past redline.
The TVA technology that Kang created was no
longer powerful enough to erase the nexus
event in the new branch matured into a fully
alternate reality.
Now obviously the reason for controlling all
this on Loki was a little bit different.
The he who remains version of Kang created
the sacred timeline which is basically his
original timeline to prevent all the other
king variants from the multiverse from destroying
all of reality the what if series is taking
just a slightly different spin on that like
off in a different part of the multiverse
events are conspiring to FUBAR the entire multiverse
The same way that the Kang multiverse war
will but just using different characters to do that
It wasn't clear the marvel producers the what
if people Kevin Feige clarified that the what
if series is canon to the MCU.
Although you should think of it is the Marvel
cinematic multiverse now you can make the
joke that everything is now Canon through
the multiverse.
Technically also be talking about this when
we get into venom.
Let there be carnage videos is well talking
about Tom Holland's Spider-Man crossover post
credit scenes all that stuff during the what
if intro graphic of the shattering prisms.
That's meant to be a different representation
of the Loki effect of creating branch timelines.
But as you can also see from this new trailer
their still a couple major avengers characters
from other universes that we have not met
yet in the episodes the biggest one being
party Thor whose being voiced by Chris Hemsworth
he they come back to do is episodes Ultron
who I think they're calling the infinite Ultron
because he's the one who gets the six infinity
stones and vision's body.
This version, a black widow with Captain America
shield or an alternate version of Captain
America shield in alternate Ronin version
of Hawkeye in Captain marvel at least there
could be more characters they just know show
up in this trailer there only three more episode,
so I'm assuming that the next one or two episodes
will finish introducing all the new characters,
then either the last episode.
Like episode nine or the last two episodes
will be them doing the actual big multiverse
version of the avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame event where and based on some of this
footage in the way the characters are talking
they fight both the infinity gauntlet version
of Ultron vision's body.
But also the same time.
While they're fighting him in his army of
Ultron robots it seems like marvel zombies
travels the multiverse.
Like they did in the comics, and also join
the battle and ego the living planet joins
with his version of Peter Quill to FUBAR their
universe and possibly escalate things to a
multiverse level threat, so a bare minimum
is sort of a four-way standoff avengers endgame
situation where you have the multiverse avengers
coming together from all the different universes
that Ultron and his army the marvel zombies
then ego the living planet, who gets a huge upgrade
I did have a theory during my what if episode
five marvel zombies video.
Because Janet van dyne was the patient zero
for their universe and they were blaming the
zombie outbreak on a quantum virus that he's
of the zombies themselves could use Hank Pym
and Janet van dyne the quantum tech to reenter
the quantum realm and use that to travel to
other universes in infect the rest of the
multiverse.
Which is kind of what happened in the comics,
although they use the different way to travel
the multiverse or the quantum virus could
just spread through the multiverse on its
own infecting other realities, if it's quantum
in nature than it already has a connection
to the multiverse is remember in the marvel
multiverse.
There are infinite universes.
But only one quantum realm the quantum realm
is sort of like the connective tissue between
all different universes that's why in the
marvel movies, the avengers are able to use
that to travel to different points in the
timeline in different realities.
It also why Kang the conqueror is going to
be the main villain of Antman three quantumania.
Because all the Kang's used quantum energy
to travel to different realities and start
the Kang multiverse war if it wasn't obvious
from this trailer all the characters that
they highlight in the trailer are meant to
be the characters that will participate in
the major multiverse avengers team up crossover
that's why they shout them all out in the
trailer I love the joke about there being
two versions of Doctor Strange Doctor Strange
and Doctor Strange.
But as you can see pretty much all the major
characters from each of the episodes are coming
back in for instance, there continuing at
least some of the stories in the different
universes for instance you see Captain Carter
she's wearing the winter soldier stealth version
of her costume.
Like Captain America's stealth costume from
the winter soldier movie.
Just this past weekend what if episode six
Kilmonger is able to take the throne of Wakanda
and become the next Black Panther a lot of
you were like okay you know his plan to use
Wakanda conquer the world seems like it's
going to happen in this reality why didn't
they show us that happening because that would
be pretty cool to see here's the thing with
Captain Carter getting the new costume in
some of the other characters that seem like
they had minor changes.
If you remember some of the earlier trailers
you cannot she see scenes of Pepper Potts
shuri and the Dora Milaje fighting together
and Wakanda against Kilmonger Black Panther
so clearly they intend on paying off the set
up at the end of episode six and some of these other episodes
Like we see footage of ego the living planet
after the end of episode to where he came
to get Peter Quill the Dairy Queen.
But you didn't see what happened right after
that the watcher just implies that things
are good and really badly for this universe.
But here you can see him in the moments after
that scene merging with his Peter Quill using
their combined celestial energy to complete
his plan of terraforming their universe.
But here's the thing, there's only three episodes
left.
So I'm wondering if there can it continue
all these different universe storylines in
a single combined episode, so use one episode
to tell you what happened after the end of
all the different episodes may be like the
end of episode seven though starter episode
eight just them showing you what happens next
in all the different universes, then while
the wrapping that up something else happens
to explain how they FUBAR all of reality and
start crossing over all the different avengers
characters in the episodes paying off the
big guardians of the multiverse in the finale
one of my few minor complaints about the what
if episode so far is that I think they played
it way to safe with the story twist in some
of the episodes like they could've gone way
crazier really good example is the dark Doctor Strange episode
It was fantastic feel like they didn't actually
lean into the marvel of it all quite enough,
like didn't serialize the story enough with
proper post credit scenes to help hype up
the multiverse crossover from the start.
The way you would expect them to do with post
credit scenes in marvel movies that we should've
seen at least a couple post credit scenes
by now making it clear that the multiverse
crossover was going to happen.
The only way you have known about that would
be if you watched all the trailers with a
fine tooth comb.
Like zoom and enhance on all the different
frames or if you watch my videos.
Hopefully they'll use this to retune the episodes
for season 2.
Just make it like a little bit clear and get
a little bit crazier also if you didn't know
they are doing Loki season 2.
I've already done a couple videos about that.
Some of the marvel Disney plus series will
get season two's and what's can happen after
the what if finale if it wasn't clear is that
the Hawkeye series will be like the next big
marvel Disney plus series.
But that's not starting to the end of November.
I boarded than a couple big Hawkeye trailer
video.
So a link those at the end of this and done
in the description.
But the other big thing you probably realized
about this giant what if multiverse crossover
with all the avengers characters.
Is it is a good test case for a live action
Avengers secret wars movies series because
there's no way you could pay off a full secret
wars storyline in a single avengers movie.
Even the russos when they were promoting avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame are like
you know will be really cool to do an avengers
secret wars movies series.
We would have to do a couple movies for it.
But it will be really cool if you spotted
any other big Easter eggs in this trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video just
right them blown the comments my full what
if episode 7 video will post next week.
Just like normal.
I've got a brand-new venom let there be carnage Spider-Man crossover video
that I'm working on that will post tomorrow
make sure you have alerts enabled so you don't
miss anything.
Everyone click here for my full Hawkeye trailer
video in daredevil Easter eggs.
That's right, there's daredevil stuff going
on inside Hawkeye and click here for my full
what if episode 6 video you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you in the next video!